as things are amping up on the
bachelorette of course we're getting
equally excited for bachelor in paradise
and honey your role is being stepped up
is bigger and better this year so you
are
the master of cocktails and ceremonies
what exactly does that entail wells i
don't know if i'm being honest with you
i think they couldn't convince uh some
of the celebrities to uh stay up as late
as uh
you have to for for cocktail parties and
and
for rose ceremonies and you know i'm
there bartending so they're like yeah
throw wells in he'll do a good job
so i did take a bartending class i felt
like last year
i didn't really know what i was doing
we've got also folks helping out like
lance bass titus burgess david spade
what can we expect from from these few
guys coming in to help things out on the
hosting front
yeah you know i mean like the bachelor
the bachelorette and even bachelor in
paradise always have kind of celebrities
come in
and join for dates and kind of give
their unique perspective
which is i think what we can expect this
go-around
um obviously having like comedic
juggernauts like david spade and titus
come in
like they're gonna bring the funny and
like i want everyone to remember
that paradise is a comedy show you know
like and
we've had a rough year and a half like i
think america needs
a feel-good comedy show with a little
bit of drama and romance thrown in there
and so they're going to bring that
you know obviously lance brings
musicality and
the boy band with him so i think that's
going to be fun and a lot of people are
going to be kind of
star struck and little john just brings
like
really really good vibes
[Music]
what yeah like shockingly
can you believe it okay
like um if i'm being honest if i'm being
honest he was my favorite person
to hang out with and work with he was
so fun and funny and amazing but they
were all great
so yeah i think everyone's going to be
in for a really fun a fun ride and then
i'll be there for the for the therapy
sessions and for the drinks
and saying things like uh you know if
you do not receive a rose please take a
moment
and say your goodbyes well and those are
all familiar words that we were
quite used to hearing chris harrison
deliver
each and every episode of the franchise
so filmy just wrapped what was it like
without chris
present this season uh yeah it's
different it's a different vibe
if i'm being honest but um and i know
that like
change is always hard i i understand
that but like
at the end of the day i wish chris
nothing but the best
um and i'm just excited for everyone to
uh
get to come back and enter the gates of
paradise because uh
we had to take last year off which was a
bummer um because i truly do love
helping make the show and i think
america truly does
love coming to the gates and walking
down the steps with us so i'm just happy
that it's back
and you always bring a fun element to it
wells that you are close with chris so
what was your reaction when you heard
that he was no longer going to be
officially a part of the franchise
are we surprised yeah i was surprised
and shocked um
i think a lot of people were do you
think it was the right decision
i don't know i'm just the bartender i'm
fine but whales a lot of people are
saying a lot of fans out there are
saying they think you should step in for
chris so
what's the latest have you been asked
are there talks would you do it
uh there haven't been talks um
i those are really large shoes to fill
would you well
i just i want to be a part of the
franchise
in whatever you know aspect that they
they want me to be involved to be honest
with you i love
being i love being the bartender i you
know
the host role is one that is a little
bit separated from
from the cast if i if you're if you're
really looking at it
uh objectively and so the bartender role
is i'm entrenched with everyone i'm a
kind of a part of the landscape
um and so my relationship with them
is is a very strong one um whereas the
you know host roles has got to be a
little bit step back and a little more
objective i suppose
so i don't really know how i would how i
would do uh
you know stepping into that role but
whatever you know baxter nation
wants and what abc wants i'm
i'm happy to do but i'm just excited for
paradise i'm excited to mix up some
margaritas
and uh some drama and just watch it all
burn in front of me well hopefully no
drama for your wedding your upcoming
nuptials to miss sarah hyland i know you
guys have had to postpone because of
covid
as have so many i mean i've experienced
that as well with trying to plan my
wedding but what's the latest on you're
on the front of your wedding
you got a date locked in what's going on
wells
i don't know i don't know if i'm if i'm
being honest with you i don't we've had
a postponed twice
uh it's been such a bummer you know we
want to have this big wedding
and like you know it's a it's a disney
and abc wet dream our wedding is you
know
all the modern family and all the
bachelor people coming together
um but we couldn't because you know
covid and everything
so i don't really know what's going on i
think the idea was for us to do it
this summer um but that really
that got pushed again just because of
code restrictions
so i don't know i fingers crossed you
get to do it soon the good news is is
that like sarah's
is kind of like off shooting movies and
television shows and everything and he's
bringing us inside
yeah and i'm in paris you know working
on that so
now we're busy again so i don't really
know what's going to happen
there's a good chance that we're going
to put on some powder blue suits and
some bad
dresses and just go to vegas and get
elvis to
knock it out for us